Judy how important is the role of a
producer well not enough can be said
about the person who's the actual
hands-on producer who works with you on
day-to-day basis and for me that is my
producer is Nancy Kissick and Nancy and
I were friends long before this and had
worked on a short film together we did a
narrative film together back in 2001
something like that and when I started
working on this it became apparent to me
that while I have been able to be a
producer and a director on many projects
that this was going to be too
overwhelming and Nancy came on and I
just put all the day-to-day burdens on
her shoulders she's the one who set up
that shoot in New York of the Harlem
steps you know the poster of the photo
that was three months work up Nancy on
the phone just organizing that she's the
one who takes care of all the financial
matters who keeps us straight to it
keeps my head on straight and then she
has incredible taste so every time
Edward and I would do a cut we'd Hall
Nancy in there and she would sit down
and watch the cut with us and her
comments were usually just spot-on you
know she knows how to just say the right
thing so having somebody like that on
your team is so important because even
you and the editor you know you get so
deeply immersed in it that you can't see
it anymore and having one other person
with great taste who has the project's
best interest at heart that's what a
great producer does for you that's what
what Nancy did for us and how long have
you know I've know Nancy for probably
mmm 25 years but we just knew each other
on a friendship basis she had worked for
a major advertising agency and my
husband was working with them as well
doing the music for a lot of their
commercials and so we met socially and
we were at parties together and just you
know kind of hit it off with a
friendship and she went on to do a lot
of excuse me other producing and when I
was going to do my short film I called
her and said I need a producer so I
called Nancy and asked her if she would
want to produce that for me she did and
once we work together I started thinking
you know I'd like to work with her again
so that's what we did what are some
traits that are graded producers that
you would advise other filmmakers to
look for even if they don't have a long
IMDb lists the producer has to be
someone who is there to support your
vision and not to pull the film in
another direction that's one of the
great gifts of nancy has she's there to
support my vision and she knows how to
do it when it's required she keeps me
from falling through a lot of traps
falling through holes making mistakes
she remembers stuff that I forget it's
you know it's a real wonderful support
that's what you need Proactive exactly
proactive on top of things but knows not
to try to take it away from the director
that's that's hard how would you
recommend one find a producer boy that's
a mystery that i have never been able to
advise anybody or solve for anybody you
get out there have a career and you'll
meet people who will come into your life
and come into your circle of people that
you will want to work with and you'll
try working with them and if they don't
work out it they'll go by the wayside
but eventually you find the group that
you want to work with and it's just
trial and error and hit miss there's not
a place you go we producers are us you
know that you can just rent a producer
it's finding the right person who you
can work with what what are some of the
things
have to do to keep a producer happy I
mean it's like any relationship it's
probably a lot of give and take it some
good days some bad days well I keep my
producer happy by feeding her lunch
every day I make lunch for my entire
crew oh I do this started out as a lark
because people work here in my studio
office and I didn't want them having to
go out have lunch find a place to eat dr
come back and you know it's not like in
walking distance there's some places to
eat so I just started you know making
lunch or letting them fix lunch for
themselves but it seems to have turned
into a wonderful part of our day and
it's a time where we all get to sit
together and talk together as a group
and you know this is interesting this
new thing that happened with the CEO of
Google where she now wants people all to
come into the office and work together I
don't know if you know about this well
you know everybody's home working from
their home now because you can
everybody's in a virtual office well the
new CEO of Google realized that
something was missing by doing this and
she decided to have people come back
into an office and work together and in
doing that you start to talk about
things that don't come up when you're in
a virtual office and we find that here
that you know yesterday I threw out a
problem to my four people were sitting
out the patio having lunch and I said
okay we've got a problem here how we go
to solve this I had come up with three
or four thoughts on my own around the
table they came up with five or six more
thoughts and by the end of the day we
were implementing them so you know
there's a difference between being
virtual and being real that's that's how
I like to work with my people
you